l'expérimentation sur mathieu mathieu
vous priver de la parole comme le petit
singe donc chacun votre tour vous allez
pouvoir dire une vérité à mathieu il ne
pourra pas vous répondre
sauf avec des gestes donc on peut
bâillonner un mathieu s'il vous plaît
c'est donc j'avais de lui dire ce que
vous pensez
enfin interdiction de parler d'accord
alors on commence par benjamin mathieu
j'ai appris une chose incroyable jean
marc morandini va bien tout est invité à
dîner
non on dit rien voilà ça passe daniela
c'est quand même parce que le bâillon
mathieu est une bonne nouvelle le plan
cul tu avais une hésitation passé chez
ma mère et moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gratuit je m'attendais pas du tout à ça
jean michel mathieu
time to [ __ ] mais t'inquiète pas il ya
pire autour de la table à maxime
[Rires]
vous pouvez faire déjà ce maxi mathieu
on est plusieurs autour de la table a
trouvé que tu commences à faire ton âge
d'ailleurs quel âge as-tu 46 47 ans et
ça avec des gestes pouvaient répondre à
m mathieu toute l'équipe et moi même
nous pensons que l'amour que tu portes à
cyril très apparemment à la télévision
c'est du fait que c'est du faux c'est
pour avoir des prime mais ça c'est bien
de poser c'est que le but est qu'ils ne
répondent pas d'accord allez une petite
dernière
ja mois la production donné son accord
pour que tu sois obligé de passer les 48
prochaines heures avec moi mais avec le
bâillon sur la bouche
[Applaudissements]